hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome blindfold television game
between two former world champions uh
and before you all start writing but
isn't blindfolds television just radio
uh it's actually the game that is being
played blindfold now uh two former world
champions Mikhail boutinik and the Max
uh both incredible players that have
played uh some incredible games
throughout their careers uh it's been
some time since uh was a world champion
even by the standards of this game this
game was played 60 years ago in 1963 and
the Maxima was a champion some 26 years
he lost his world champion title to
Alexander alejin in 1937 in the rematch
and botwinica lost his world champion uh
title to to tigrant Petrosian earlier uh
the the in the year of 1963. so it's a
really wild game and a lot of theory is
being discussed here the moves they play
are are absolutely incredible it's still
a standard Theory even today uh and
what's incredible is that after all this
extensive analysis analysis that both of
them have done in their you know their
private time and even during this game
that they are playing blindfold uh the
game could have been decided by a very
simple tactic which they both overlooked
but that's where you guys will come in
and you will uh you know save the day so
let's check it out between it has the
white pieces and he opens with Pawn to
D4 like I said this was a blindfold
television game it was broadcasted uh on
the 28th of December so a few days
before New Year's uh you know always
nice when you have a chess on TV so
Knight to F6 we have C4 E6 Knight to C3
and the bishop to B4 uh that goes for
the uh names of Indian defense we have
Pawn to E3 and pawn to C5 the hypna
variation Knight to F3 we have B6 sorry
that's not a B6 B5 uh B6 Bishop to D3
and now Bishop to B7 all all uh playable
even today we have castles castles and
now Knight to A4 and now this is where
things get incredibly interesting here
the main move even today recommended by
the engine is Queen to E7 and this is
whatever played and this is what between
played um uh four months before this
game he played this game against Mark
taimanov we're also going to discuss
this but it's interesting that nowadays
everyone plays C Capt or Sandy for
there's even a game and Magnus cross and
played against Sergey kariakin uh in
2011 I was the the Kings tournaments uh
website tournament and uh the game ended
in a draw but here we have Queen the E7
uh very very strong move Ponte A3
challenges the bishop and Bishop to A5
and here uh D captures on C5 Bible tunic
and it's interesting uh here temanov
played uh when taimano played against
botwinik um uh some four months ago uh
he played B3 and he lost that game
there's nothing wrong with B3 it just
doesn't give white ball that much but
Phoenix um played a better game uh but
here uh D captures on C5 and the
taimanov mentioned that he didn't want
to play this line because he found uh a
really spectacular refutation uh from
black uh which doesn't really work but
you'll see what I mean by this uh B
captures on C5 Knight captures on C5 and
now Queen captures on C5 and this is the
star move uh that uh that plays in this
game and the reason why it wasn't played
uh in the game uh where temanova was
playing but Phoenix is that that amount
of thought that butwini could play
Bishop captures on F3 here and look at
this uh incredible line Queen captures
an F3 Queen captures on C5 and now Queen
capture 78 and not the amount of thought
that between he could trap his Queen
with Knight to C6 this attacks the queen
queen to B7 rooked the B8 attacks the
queen queen six and now okay you can't
play Rook B because of Queen to see it
but there's the silent but the deadly
Knight to the E8 and now threatening
Knight to C7 this will win the White
Queen there's only one game to save the
game the one move that saves the game
for white and that is Pawn to B4 as
there usually is uh Queen to E5 now now
The Rook on A1 is hanging as well but
now comes the star move and this is what
you have to see in order to play this
with white you have to play Bishop to B2
and give up the bishop then comes Queen
captures on B2 Rook a to B1 captures and
now Rook captures now finally you go
after the White Queen but now you give
back the queen to regain some material
captures captures captures the bishop
captures The Rook captures the rook and
now you get this position where white is
up upon it's a double Pawn but still up
a pawn if anyone wants to be preferred
here yeah it's definitely white uh so uh
the amount of uh missed this and uh he
he just to win for for an inferior B3
line and he lost the game to batwini but
here of course that doesn't have and we
have Queen captures in C5 uh Uber shows
that he's ready for uh whatever but
meaning has to throw at him and now Pawn
to B4 attacks the bishop and the queen
with Bishop captures on F3 Queen
captures and now Queen to E5 attacking
The Rook while the rook and A8 is also
hanging and the bishop here is hanging
now I will just uh include that there is
an actual footage of this game it will
be the first link in the description
below if you guys want to check it out
and if anyone uh you know by any chance
speaks Dutch I would uh very much
welcome uh if someone would translate
what the the gentleman are discussing
about the game and if someone can even
write that I will pin their comment for
everyone else to see I'm sure it's uh
it's really awesome uh it's okay here we
have B captures and A5 grabbing the
bishop Queen capture Sunny one Queen
captures an A8 and now Queen to C3 and
we get a similar uh Pawn structure here
Bishop now back to E2 and now Knights
the C6 attacks the queen defends the A7
pawn queen to B7 and now Rook the B8
with Queen into C7 and now Queen the C2
attacks the bishop and now Bishop to F3
and here between said that he felt that
he really had a powerful position that
he should uh be winning this game even
though he I mean he is up a pawn but uh
Max finds this very very nasty Pawn to
H5 move and you'll see why it's uh why
it's very annoying Bishop characters on
C6 but winning is hoping to win another
Pawn but of course uh the idea is Rook
to B1 now the bishop on C1 is hanging
and also the bishop and C6 is hanging so
here Bishop back to F3 by betweenik and
now Rook captures on C1 now you can't
capture because you get the checkmated
you have to create some uh breeding room
for the king here and now comes Knight
to the G4 this is the move that butwini
praised but it seems that in all of this
um uh you know blindfold frenzy they
both missed a very very very simple idea
which of course you guys see right away
so feel free to pause the video and win
the game for both winning while I give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh wild idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Bishop
captures and G4 I'm just kidding that's
what but Finnick played that's the move
that draws the game the move that wins
the game is Queen to B8 with check only
move for black king H7 now comes Bishop
to E4 check for King The King and the
the queen here uh and now you have to or
rather obscuring them and now you have
to capture Queen captures and you pick
up the rook and C1 Rook captures on C1
and now between it would just be up the
exchange his uh upper Pawn a completely
winning position for white there there's
really not all that much you can drive
Queen F3 just Queen F4 and no threads
here and if you try some wild ideas like
Knight E5 going for Knight to F3 check
still just Queen to B1 attacks the queen
here and you can throw in a few checks
but even King G2 uh you you can even
allow a double check here Knight D1 a
double checking F1 there's no
continuation here you have to trade
queens now captures captures and ended
the Rook will of course be much much
better than the Knight here so that was
absolutely crushing for for between but
instead he played Bishop captures on G4
he even said after the game that he was
really impressed by this setup that uh
the found and that it should be you know
perfectly fine but he missed this a very
cool idea of Queen B8 Bishop T4 check so
he captured here uh we have Rook
captures on F1 King characters H captors
and G4 and now even Queen captures on A7
uh the way to maybe play for a win here
is the is to just go queen d8 king H7
Queen to H for check and pick up the G4
Pawn because this is the pawn that
really stifles White's position and now
uh I mean this is uh yeah it's a queen
and pawn end game okay white is that
material but uh Queen and pawn is hard
to win even with side the blindfold uh I
mean their heads would would just
explode playing this yeah so I think
that's why he it's a television game he
just didn't want to over press it he's
played Queen captures on A7 and now he
allowed the Perpetual here Queen to D1
checking G2 Queen F3 check King the F1
and of course this now ended in a
Perpetual after Queen to F3 I think uh
yeah on move 26. so even though there's
a lot to discuss so many cool lines to
to actually check out who what happens
if this is what happens in that uh the
entire game lasted only 26 moves so
really incredible stuff by two former
world champions uh but Phoenix and uh
and yeah like I said uh do click on it
and the first link in the description
below you can watch it you can listen to
their discussion about the game after
the actual game was played and if anyone
can give us a transcript I would be very
very grateful and I'm sure a lot of
people would uh so yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed a little bit of
History regarding the game uh I would
like to thank seconka travel and tour
safaris Jordan Smith
Berry day and Lobo for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions uh and whatever else happens
in the the Chess World so thank you all
I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and also I
forgot this game comes as a suggestion
from Ahmed Banerjee uh so really thank
you for that it was a really wonderful
game to prepare and present to everyone
see you soon